we have huge iPhone news for you today
say it with us 10 this not X it is the
biggest leap forward since the original
iPhone it's a 5.8 inch phone with a
practically bezel s super high res OLED
screen a stainless steel edge wrapping
case wireless charging and a bunch of
new cameras still no headphone jack
obviously but hopefully you weren't too
attached to the home button because now
that's gone to look at it and it
recognizes you say goodbye to touch ID
say hello to face ID face ID learns your
face even if you change your hairstyle
you decide to put on glasses you're
wearing a hat so you do it up anyway you
do it
face ID learns your face thanks to a
bunch of sensors and cameras in that
little notch at the top of the screen
unlocking your phone is now as simple as
looking at it those sensors also track
your faces position in real time which
means nuttier snaps incredible metallic
reflections the quality of the tracking
it's it's just stunning and thanks to a
new feature called an emoji mapping your
facial expressions to chickens unicorns
and piles of poop welcome to the future
everybody making all of this possible is
Apple's new a 11 Bionic chip which runs
facial recognition right from your phone
pre-orders start October 27th with the
64 gig model starting at $999 iPhone 10
will ship on November 3rd if a
thousand-dollar phone sounds too
expensive or you just don't want Apple
tracking your face there's the
redesigned iPhone 8 iPhone a
iPhone 8 this is a huge step forward for
iPhone like the iPhone 10 it's got a
true tone screen that adjusts the
display for different lighting
conditions a glass back for wireless
charging and an A 11 chip that our
cameras motion sensors and graphics let
the phone render augmented reality
environments in real time and the iPhone
8 plus and the iPhone 10 will both get a
new feature called portrait lighting
later this year you see machine learning
it creates facial landmarks and actually
changes the lighting of the contours
over your face the iPhone 8 comes in
silver Space Gray and a new gold finish
and starts at six hundred ninety nine
dollars for the eight and seven ninety
nine for the eight plus pre-orders
starts September 15th with the phones
hitting stores a week later
introducing Apple watch series three and
it has cellular built in also coming
this month is Apple watch series three
it now comes with LTE connectivity built
in so you can field phone calls access
maps talk to Siri and stream music to
your wrist all without a phone inside is
a new dual-core processor delivering up
to 70% more more performance it's really
really fast and a built-in altimeter now
lets you track elevation change on runs
and hikes all that new tech lives in a
case just a fraction of a millimeter
thicker than the previous version what
else
all the LTE enabled watches will come
with a red accent on the crown the fancy
ceramic model now comes in gray but the
rose gold aluminum model is no more oh
and keep an eye out for a bunch of new
bands including crisi options from their
mess and a less expensive fabric fan
that Apple calls in the sport loop the
new watches start at 329 without LTE 399
with LTE and go up from there pre-orders
start September 15 with shipments
beginning a week later
and finally Apple today announced a
brand new version of Apple TV Apple TV
4k it looks a lot like the old set-top
box only now it supports 4k and HDR
content and a lot more of it with live
sports and news and movies and TV from
partners like Netflix and Amazon oh and
if you already bought an HD movie on
iTunes Apple says it'll upgrade it to 4k
HDR for free the whole package runs on
an a 10x fusion chip same as the one
you'll find in the iPad pro and the new
Apple TV isn't just slightly faster it's
remarkably faster you can order the
Apple TV 4k starting at 1 in 79 for the
32 gig model beginning September 15th or
grab one in stores starting on the 22nd